good morning Baker how are you doing
great how are you where are you right
now I'm great I I'm in the locker room
right now what's it smell like in there
just fresh roses in a meadow that
doesn't smell like any locker room that
I used to be in yeah it's pretty nice
new facility so it's actually they did a
great job great ventilation system so it
actually airs it out pretty well what's
the schedule today right now just kind
of hanging out but there was some film
and then we'll go from there we have
meetings starting at 1:30 so I'll get
that going and then just get ready for
Kansas from there any classes not today
today we had Rick Neuheisel on first
hour of the show former former head
coach now working for CBS and Seaton
could you play this for a Baker Mayfield
on if he was drafting who would he take
first if I have to take the quarterback
I think I'm going Mayfield
I just I just like the kids swagger I
like his ability to make plays he's all
football all the time over Rosen worried
about yeah and I love Rosen I I love
Rosen but I had the question for me with
Rosen is how important is football to
Rosa yeah I I don't know that it's it's
everything and for Mayfield he's passed
that test and with in spades
what do you think of that pretty big
honor I mean especially the UCLA guys so
humbling so I mean it's pretty cool I
didn't know if you maybe stayed a year
too long because that usually that's
what happens like people get tired of
seeing quarterbacks and then we dissect
them matt barkley matt leinart how close
were you to coming out last year
um really not that close but not of
course as people might have thought you
know I when I came down to it at one to
win a national title and I had a lot of
people here that I wanted to play for
and then that I wanted to be around for
another year so I mean it wasn't I
thought about it a little bit but when I
came down to it the best days in Korea
was coming back do you play with the
chip on your shoulder Boulder I think
why why a boulder on your shoulder I
think the best ones there's an edge I
think you know what to have the
intensity and the mindset in that you're
going to go in and prove yourself each
week no matter who it is I think the
best ones do it I think Brady does it
weekend a week out everyday so it's just
all right I believe it's the best way to
handle myself and I've had successes
it's knocking stuff who do you who plays
in the pros the way you think you play
or can play I think I'd like to thank
you you know I'd take a little bit some
stuff and a couple people you know I'd
like to be able to have the command of
the offense like Brady and I'd like to
say that I could move around not as well
as Russell Wilson but attempt to and
then just be in the pocket like Drew
Brees I think I'd aspire to be a little
bit of everything I mean those guys are
all integrated what they do so I think I
can learn and you know try to be like
them and that'd be a good model but
you're not an underdog anymore I
understand playing with a chip on your
shoulder here you are
by all accounts leading contender for
the Heisman your team is nine and one
you got guys who are praising you about
being a first-round draft pick yeah how
do you how do you stay hungry with that
because now they're saying all the
things that maybe you didn't hear the
first couple of years there at Oklahoma
Wow it just goes to show that they
weren't there force in the beginning now
I just this is how it is it's goes
people want to jump on the bandwagon
late but we're not about that so I'm
gonna keep the same mindset I'm gonna
make sure our team does as well after
the Iowa State game held down were you
oh you don't more disappointed than
anything just really disappointed just
how we played because we're so much
better than what we performed and and
now we you know showed that so we didn't
need a loft to Kickstarter season or or
get our minds right and that was the
biggest thing for me it was just
disappointing more than anything you
know Tess has two seasons
we had needed you know maybe to have our
backs against the wall to play well but
we have a special team I don't think we
needed that at that point so it was like
I said more disappointing than making
its Baker Mayfield Oklahoma quarterback
joining us I think one of the most
impressive stats this is what I love is
that you're great on road games 13 and
oh and true road games as a sooner
completing 71 percent of your passes you
must love that atmosphere of being the
villain walking into a building you know
like I said I think when we play with an
edge were the best yeah that's when
we're at our best and you know more on
the road is just it's perfect
environment right oh you go on it they
don't want you there they'd really come
up the tunnel or the locker room and
then after that it's just just you and
your guys against everybody else have
you ever done a Heisman posed before
publicly or privately they force me to
do one in New York City last year with
with all the guys that I think it's been
a long time before that it's the only
one I can really remember do you care
about the Heisman I mean yeah there's a
huge honor and very special to me but I
care more about one of the national
caudill to be honest and I got you 31
touchdown passes didn't I say that you
would get two if you got 240 then I
would help you with Timberlake also
you're going to get nine touchdown
passes you might get that against Kansas
this weekend you know young players that
are playing well defensively their front
lines they got some sounds of guys
all right when you get to 40 touchdown
passes we'd like the bandana here to
hang in the man cave right right we'll
take it take it easy on Kansas I know
that there are there you know upcoming
program and that defensive front you're
worried about and all those blah blah
blah blah blah but good luck with that
all right now this could be a trap game
after the TCU game so I understand that
right could be a letdown now it's your
job as the leader - you know rally the
troops and tell them hey Dan Patrick
said we might letdown against Kansas
let's show him that we will not all
right I like that oh I might have to
take the blame there hey Baker great to
talk to you and congrats so far that's
Baker Mayfield jr. the third for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]